Okay.
Good afternoon, everybody.
Bonjour. It's my pleasure to open this session.
So please,
before we really start, you have to scan this QR code because
this is a way of asking questions. And second, I have to
apologize for whoever has made this mistake in this slide.
We are not going to talk about NK cells-based cancer,
as you can imagine. NK cell-based cancer therapies. Okay.
That said, so did you scan the QR code? Okay, thank you.
Now we can switch
to-- Yes. That's what I have to do now.
Here we go.
Okay.
Yes, so thanks again for being here.
So I won't be long for the introduction.
Just to remind you that NK cells, as you know,
belong to a larger family of innate lymphocytes,
innate lymphoid cells that we also call ILCs.
I remind you that these ILCs are coming different flavors.
As you can see here, you have ILC1s, which are very
close cousins of NK cells. You have ILC2s that
produce Th2 cytokines and ILC3s
that produce Th17,
Th22-like cytokines such as IL-17,
IL-22, and GM-CSF.
So this session will be dedicated to NK cells only,
and we have a lot to say about these cells.
Just also to remind you that
we collectively think that these cells are really
interesting to study for a number of reasons, in particular in the context of
cancer and innovative cancer therapies because, first of
all, they recognize cancer cells.
And they do that through a panel, a variety of
activating cell surface receptors,
which can be antagonized, as you know, by inhibitory
molecules that recognize, in particular MHC class I.
But the detection of stress cells is really something very
important. It's also important probably to mention that NK cells
can fight against tumor cells with low mutation load,
which is something against which T cells are really not
very operative.
Also, another point to mention is that NK cells can
actually not only control some
cancers, solid tumors, we'll come back to that, but also
hematologic malignancies. But they have also the propensity to recognize
and control metastasis,
which is a very important feature.
And finally,
work from many different labs, and we'll hear about the beautiful work
of Rhys Evan-Harri
in the next presentation. We know that NK cells can be
used in adoptive transfer,
with very nice safety profile and hopefully,
some nice efficacy as well.
So I would like also to remind you that NK cells are not only killer cells.
They're able to produce an array of chemokines and cytokines,
as illustrated in that slide. In particular, they can contribute to the
activation of dendritic cells, as you can appreciate here.
When NK cells, through the production of CXCL1, CCL5, and Fas
ligand, participate to the activation of CDC1,
which are themselves very important for the
cross-presentation of tumor antigen to T cells.
So
this is why some of us are really NK cell maniacs,
so to speak, trying to stimulate NK cells in the context of
cancer to boost their activity against cancer cells,
but also to boost their activity to participate
to the onset and the maintenance and the shaping of
a broader immune response, including T cells.
And this is what is represented here, with this
NK cell, which would be here as ILCs.
And one stimulates NK cells, one can try to have these
two hits with one stone.
So now we'll switch to my own
presentation. Here we go.
If I can do that.
And this is it. So this is my disclosure slide.
It turns out that this disclosure slide will have some importance,
as I will be presenting data that have been obtained at Innate Pharma,
a biotech company that you might have heard of.
So first, I would like to remind you what are NK cells.
And we and others, as illustrated here,
have joined forces to try to use single-cell
technologies using CITE-seq and single-cell RNA-seq in
particular, to try to describe the
heterogeneity of NK cells across species.
In the interest of time today, I will just present you data that we
have obtained in humans. But keep in mind that,
and stay tuned, because we have data that are confirming
earlier work that we have published that will
reveal that in fact the nomenclature
of NK cell that we are proposing as NK1, NK2, and
NK3 also holds true in the mouse.
But let's start by this slide. So what we've been doing
is analyzing, as I said, different kind of data, data that
we have generated for the purpose of this study, but also
we have done some meta-analysis of data sets that are
available. And at the end of the day, we have
collected data for more than 700
donors,
healthy individuals and cancer patients.
And
at the end of the day, is the largest collection of single cellThat
are obtained with NK cells. And so, as I said,
NK cells can be at very high level described
in three subset, NK1, NK2, and NK3.
So let me first tell you that NK1 doesn't mean that those are
NK cells with type one immunity or NK2 with
type two immunity. It could have been NK A, B, C, but we
collectively decided to call them NK1, NK2, and NK3.
And the prominent NK cell subset in human peripheral
blood, I'm speaking about healthy individuals, are NK1s.
Okay? And NK2s are represented here.
They correspond to what was called previously CD56
bright NK cells. I would like to insist that even though the
cell surface expression of CD56, which I remind you
is an isoform of NCAM, has been quite
important for describing the heterogeneity of human NK cells.
It turns out that CD56 is not expressed on mouse NK cells.
So if we want to come up with a description of NK cells
across species, it's important to go beyond
CD56. And that's why it's so important that this
NK1, NK2 subset that I will be describing to you right now
are also conserved in the maps. So, as I said, NK1 is the
largest subset of NK cells. This is a so-called CD56 dim
NK cell that express high level of CD16.
And pay attention to the cytokines that they produce.
Here we are
highlighting that they produce CCL3 and CCL4, whereas
NK2s will be the one producing the XL1 cytokine that
I mentioned earlier. And the NK3 subset is quite interesting
because it corresponds to the subset of adaptive NK cells, which
have some features close to memory cells, memory
T cells in particular. And those cells are
expanding in the context of prior infection or
stimulation, in particular in the context of CMV.
You have an increase in the size of this subset of
NK3, as NK cells can recognize CMV infected
cells through NKG2C in particular. Bonjour, Laurence.
Now you can also use this classification of NK
cells across cancer types. And as you can
see here, one can see that
the frequency of different subset of NK cells
varies considerably across tumor type.
And this is very important in particular when one looks
at
this particular type of cancer here, you can appreciate that there is a
lot of NK2s, which is not the case in steady state
conditions.
Also, something which is not surprising but is very important to know is
that when you sample the blood,
you have a very blurred image of what's going on at the tumor
site.
Okay, so with this in mind, I would like to share data that we have obtained in
collaboration with lab of Alfred
Zipelius
at Basel, trying to focus on lung cancer, in
particular non-small cell lung cancer, which are coming in different
flavors, as you know, because this is a very important unmet medical
need. And using this strategy of
single cell RNA seq to look at NK cells' heterogeneity, here
using lung samples
from these cancer patients, one could appreciate that there is in
fact a very large increase in this subset of
tumor associated NK cells.
And to make a long story short, we could describe that this subset of
cells classify as NK3s, meaning cells that
have been stimulated previously.
These cells express CD39, and I'll come back to that.
They also express CD103 and CD49b,
which are marker of tissue residency.
So it was important to try to find out
what this subset was about. In particular, we've been able to
correlate the presence of large subset of tumor
associated NK3s with better prognosis for the
patient. And you can see that in two different flavors.
On the left hand side, you can appreciate that in the context of lung
adenocarcinoma,
the increase
in this size of the tumor associated
NK3 is associated with a better
survival for the patient, as you can see
here. The same is true when patients are treated with
anti-PD-1. You can appreciate that, again,
the presence of this subset of NK cell
in the tumor is associated with a better prognosis.
So we've been using, again, these technologies to try to know
more about the biology of this subset of tumor associated
NK cells. And again, to make a long story short, we could
discriminate between three different flavors of these tumor
associated NK3s in lung cancer. And what we
are proposing is actually this trajectory, which is represented here
on your right hand side, meaning that it starts with a subset of
NK cells expressing Granzyme K. I would like to mention at this
stage that Granzyme K is a very interesting molecule, the biology of which
remain to be totally dissected and understood.
It's a good marker also of T cells
engaging into trajectory of exhausted,
I don't like this term, but let's say tumor associated T cells.
But the point here is that we could propose that in
fact these cells which express Granzyme K and again
are increased in the lung cancer
upon some
interferonstimuli can actually
become the subset of NK3 that express CD39, as I
told you,
but also NKG2A. And I would like to mention
something about NKG2A, because NKG2A is a very interesting cell
surface receptor. It's a prototypical ITIM-bearing
molecule that engages a particular
MHC class 1 molecule, which is called HLA-E.
And actually, when HLA-E is
binding to NKG2A, it extinguishes or impairs NK
cell function. So we've been interrogating using
a patient-derived fragment of the tumor, whether
actually one could unleash the function of these tumor-associated
NK cells using antibodies against NKG2A.
And here we have been using an antibody that has been developed by Innate Pharma,
which is called Monalizumab, which is an antibody that blocks the
interaction between NKG2A and its ligand,
which is HLA-E. And as you can see here, so first of all,
when we look at this fraction of cells that express CD103,
CD49a, and CD39, you can
appreciate that the cells that express CD39 express higher level of
NKG2A. And when we unleash these cells using
anti-NKG2A antibody, we can actually increase the activation of
NK cells,
using the tumor tissue of the patient himself in an
autologous experimental setting, as you can appreciate.
So here we have been looking at the expression of granzyme A and granzyme B,
but the same is true with other readout of NK cell activation.
That means that in this tumor
tissue, there are cells, NK cells, that accumulate,
which can be unleashed using anti-NKG2A antibody.
And this allows me to remind you that there are different
ways of trying to use NK cells in the concept of cancer
therapies. And one of these modalities is actually to
unleash NK cells, as we have
shown previously. This is a slide derived from the work of
Innate Pharma, in which you can appreciate that NKG2A is not
only expressed on NK cells, but is also expressed on a subset of
CD8 T cells. Interestingly,
a subset of CD8 T cells which also express PD-1.
So here the idea was actually to try to
promote in the patient the total unleashing, so to speak,
of the activity of both NK cells and T cells
by combining the blockade of this PD-1, PD-L1 axis
to the blockade of the NKG2A, HLA-E axis.
And this is what has been performed by our colleagues of
AstraZeneca in collaboration with Innate Pharma.
This is a result of a phase 2 clinical trial that has been published
already some years ago called COAST, in which patients have
received
chemo and radio. Those are patients having non-small cell lung
carcinoma, stage 3, non-resectable, not metastatic.
And after a washout, they received a consolidation
treatment using either Durvalumab, which is an anti-PD-L1
antibody, as you know, which has been approved in this disease
condition,
or a combination of Monalizumab and Durvalumab.
And you can see that for this patient with PDL total cancer more
than 1%, you have a very huge increase in
the PFS after 12 months, as you can appreciate,
from 30-ish percent to more than 90%
in terms of PFS. So this led to a phase 3
clinical trial called PACIFIC 9,
for which all the patients have been
included, 1,051 patients. And we are looking forward
to the result of this interesting phase 3 clinical trial.
Now I would like to switch gears and remind you that there are multiple ways of
using NK cells in the context of cancer, and
besides the possibility of unleashing NK cells,
trying to
work
on these inhibitory MHC class 1 receptors,
one can also try to
act on the activating receptors which are expressed on NK cells.
And
this is what we have been doing at Innate Pharma, generating these
NK cell engagers that we call antibody-based NK cell engager
therapeutics. And you can see here first version of these NK
cell engagers, which as you can see, are made or generated
of three different antibody fragments.
The first one is actually an Fab, could have been a
single-chain Fv,
targeting a tumor antigen. And the first molecule that
we have put into the clinic was in collaboration with our colleagues at
Sanofi,
targeting CD123 in the context of acute myeloid leukemia.
So that's part one of this tri-specific NK cell engager.
The two other parts in red and green are actually anchoring the
NK cell engager on the NK cell side.
Here by an Fab against NKp46. I remind you
that NKp46 is a cell surface receptor expressed on
NK cells, almost exclusively on NK cells.
It's also a strong activating receptor.
And it's an agonist antibody, meaning that the binding of
this Fab induce the activation of NK cells in
terms of cytolytic activity and cytokine and chemokine
secretion. And this is completed by Fc gamma 1
here that is included in this tri-specific NK cell
engager to coligate NKp46 with a
cognate receptor, activating receptor for Fc gamma 1, which is
C16. So the good news, and this has been
published,Is that in fact,
in the first cohort of patients,
we had quite interesting complete remission in patients
with relapse or refractory AML, leading to
fast track designation by FDA.
The second molecule that we put into the clinic, again with our colleague at
Sanofi,
was actually this molecule that we have published very recently,
which target BCMA in the context, obviously, of multiple myeloma.
And as you can see here, at the preclinical level using in vitro assays,
one can compare the activity of this tri-specific NK cell
engager to an IgG1 intact antibody
targeting BCMA. Here in green, you can appreciate that
there is a
better
potency of this asset as compared to
this IgG1 BCMA antibody.
Interestingly, we've been also able, in collaboration again with our
colleague at Sanofi, to
test the activity of this tri-specific NK cell
engager targeting BCMA in a mouse model, in an
humanized mouse model, in which human NK cells have been
pre-activated in vitro, then infused into
an immunodeficient mouse, which has been afterwards targeted,
challenged, I should say, with a BCMA-expressing tumor cell.
And as you can see, this NK cell engager is having quite
interesting preclinical activity.
But so besides these tri-specific NK cell engagers,
we have realized that we could incorporate
another moiety into this tri-specific
scaffold to make a tetra-specific NK cell engager.
And the first molecule that we have incorporated is actually a variant of
IL-2, a non-alpha IL-2, in order to induce NK
cell proliferation. And what you can see using, again,
this
documentation of NK1, NK2, and NK3, you can
appreciate that upon four hours of stimulation in vitro of
human peripheral blood, one can see a major shift in
the transcriptomic,
in the transcriptome of these cells as you can see, which is
true for NK1, NK2, and NK3, making
sense because all NK cells expressing
KP46. But you have also, here, the
appearance of this new subset in brown, which correspond
to cells that have features of cytokine-induced
memory like NK cells, which is very good news, because those cells, and
I'm sure that
Rhazan will talk about these cells more,
have better effector function and higher half-life.
So at the preclinical level, you can appreciate that this
tetra-specific NK cell engager here targeting CD20,
here the mice have been challenged with a human CD20 B
cell line, are quite efficient.
But mechanistically, this nice
control is associated with a major
invasion of the tumor bed by NK cells, as you can see in
brown. And those cells are not only NK cells, they are activated NK
cells. They also express granzyme B.
But we decided that we could actually
explore other cytokines that could be
incorporated into this scaffold of NK cell
engagers. And this is what we have done more recently, using a
variant of interferon alpha.
And the reason is that interferon alpha is a very good activator
of NK cell
effector function as well. So we took advantage of
preclinical models in which the tri-specific NK cell
engager or the tetra-specific NK cell engager that
carries IL-2 was not efficient to test
whether this tetra-specific NK cell engager that
carries interferon alpha could have some function.
And you can appreciate that in this model of MC38
transfected with human CD20, we are still targeting CD20 as a tumor
antigen.
Indeed, when we change IL-2 by interferon
alpha, we have much better control, which is quite
interesting, I think.
In another model, this is a xenograft model using
immunodeficient mice,
challenged with Raji B cell line expressing human CD20.
You can appreciate that there is a nice control as well, and this control
is dependent upon NK cells.
So to conclude,
I wanted to share with you that one can describe the heterogeneity of NK
cells using NK1, NK2, and NK3, and not
shown, I'm telling you that it's also true in the mouse.
So I think it's quite nice because one can finally have a cross-species
definition of NK cell heterogeneity.
I've been telling you about these cells, which are CD39-plus
that express NK2A,
that are present and functional in lung
cancer, which is good news, and one can unleash those cells even better
using monalizumab, the anti-NK2A antibody.
And finally, I've been telling you about the possibility of using
NK cell engagers anchored on NKp46 and
CD16 and harboring on them
IL-22 or type I interferon. The last thing I would like to
share with you is that the future is not only there.
Because all these assets have been produced in vitro.
I think that one path for the future is to produce some of these assets in vivo
using LNPs, for example, and I wish I can
tell you more next time we meet. And also, beyond cancer, I
know that it's ACR, but still.It's important to see
that there are other possibilities of using NK cells in other
conditions. And this slide just to tell you that when we
use the tetra-specific NK cell engager
targeting CD20 and carrying IL-2, we
could induce a profound depletion of
normal B cells in this monkey. Not only the blood, but also his
secondary lymphoid organ, and as others, one can
maybe think of using this asset in the context of autoimmunity.
So I would like to finish here. I'm not too late, which is good.
Thanking all the people at Innate Pharma who have contributed to
all the work on NK cell engagers, plus the work on
monalizumab, and people in my lab who have contributed to the
definition of NK cells across species using single cell RNAseq
technology.
And the last point is that we are building a new city, literally a
new city dedicated to cancer, around Gustave Roussy, close
to Paris. So if you're interested, there's a QR code as well.
It's not for the question for this session.
And so don't hesitate to contact me. Okay.
I'll stop here, and if you have any question, we'll take a few of them
before going to the next speaker. Thank you very much.
I'm not sure there are any question.
Maybe I should...
Yeah, just one.
Sure.
Yeah. Also with the NK1 and NK2, is it-
There is a mic. You should go on the mic.
Yeah.
I don't know to read the questions online.
Yeah. Just a naive question. Is it a switch on the
state of the cells or they are completely different, is differentiated cells?
Yes, that's a good point. So we have published this.
In fact, we have data supporting the idea that the NK1 and the
NK2s are of different origin.
And so we have the same kind of data also in the
mouse. I don't want to go in detail into the innate and
voice cell differentiation, but NK1 and NK2 are not the same
cells with different states, which is not true for NK3s.
We do think that NK3s are coming from NK1s.
Okay. If there are no other questions, Rizvan.
So it's a pleasure to welcome Rizvan Homi from the
Dana-Farber Cancer Institute. He has been one of the pioneer
of using NK cells
as a drug, and he will let you know more about this.
Thank you, Rizvan.
Thanks, Eric, for the kind introduction.
Some of my relevant disclosures.
Dr. Vieira mentioned about the cytokine-induced memory like NK cells, as you know
that the NK cells, one of the biggest short limitations or
shortcomings of using conventional NK cells is that their half-life is only
10 to 12 days. So if you adopt a transfer of regular NK cells without
any specific cytokine support, they don't last long.
My postdoc back in, oh, God, that's a long time back,
2012, time flies by, at Wash U, we were interested
in trying to figure out a few different combination of cytokines, what will happen
to human NK cells. And we found that if you activate
NK cells with a cocktail of IL-12, 15 and 18, primarily 12
and 18, 15 being just a survival factor, they differentiate into
this memory-like phenotype, which has this interesting
property that these memory-like NK cells have not only
enhanced functionality as shown here by
increased interferon gamma, but then also they live longer.
In, for example, in a syngenic mouse model, they live up to 60 days,
and we have patient data as well. So based on this
finding that these can live longer, we did several clinical trials,
and the basic platform is shown in the schema, will take either a
haploidentical donor family member, HLA mismatch, or
more recently, patient's own blood, and separate the NK cells
using Miltenyi beads,
very purified population. Then overnight, just overnight, activate with
the IL-15, 12, and 18, the same cytokine cocktail which
led to the differentiation of memory-like NK cell, and then wash them and infuse
in the patients after they received flu psy.
We would often give low-dose IL-2 or in some trials, long-acting
IL-15 to further help these NK cells proliferate and activate in
vivo.
We did several trials. The first in human trial was led by me at Wash
U, where I described the human memory-like NK cells with Todd
Fehniger's group.
Since then, I moved to Dana-Farber and Harvard Medical School,
where we are continuing to work on these cells.
And, this is a trial at Dana-Farber where we infused
memory-like NK cells in patients who had relapsed after stem cell
transplant. So these are AML MDS patients.
This cohort particular is all AML.
They lapsed after a transplant, and we gave memory-like NK cells from the same
patient or, excuse me, same donor who gave their stem cell graft.
Now why is that important? Because these patients still maintain the T
cell donor chimerism. That means these cells would not be rejected by the
T cells because those T cells are from the same donor who is now giving
the memory-like NK cells. But yet they were HLA mismatched, so we could gate
on them, and you can see how long they will survive.
And these are color-coded here that you can see most of the NK
cells on the x-axis of the days after adoptive transfer.
As you can see, that most of these NK cells survived 60 to 90 days, which is
exactly what we had previously shown in syngenic mouse
models. And then some patients, at this couple of them, they
lasted even more, one, 180 days and one, 200 and some
18 days. So like eight months, and you can see the number of absolute NK cells
circling in the blood.We treated a total of eight patients.
Four cleared their disease, which is pretty remarkable for this patient cohort.
But yet,
the duration of responses were only four to six months.
Now, we were kind of naive to thinking that once these patients were clear of
disease, we'll just monitor them and not do anything else.
I think that we learned that in AML especially, no
destination therapy can be good enough unless you follow by another transplant or
some maintenance.
Over the years, we have published several papers, including this paper, which is
published in JCI.
We also tried this approach in really advanced head and
neck cancer. The reason for choosing head and neck cancer, there's
data to suggest that in head and neck cancer, just like how
Professor Viva showed that in some of the lung cancer patients, the
increased infiltration of NK cells associated with better prognosis.
Similarly, in head and neck cancer, multiple groups have shown
that increased infiltration of NK cells in those patients, irrespective of their
HPV status, is associated with better prognosis.
So why not take advantage of that phenomenon?
In this case, we took family members, haploidentical donor, so HLA
mismatch, converted the memory-like NKs and gave into the patients after
lymphodepletion with flucy. We also included one dose of
ipilimumab, which is a CTLA-4 blocker approved for multiple
malignancies. The reason for choosing ipilimumab was that there is,
at least in some murine data, that
CTLA-4 blockade can abrogate or can deplete,
rather, Tregs by inducing ADCC. Because remember,
Tregs help constitute expression of CTLA-4.
So we thought we'll take advantage of the NK cells combining the ipilimumab
targeting the Tregs. And then extra IL-2, we gave four
dose of long-acting anti-SL3, which is now approved for bladder
cancer.
But nonetheless, we combined here.
And what we found was in highly refractory patients, these are
five lines or more therapy, all of them having failed
the standard of care, as well as most of them having failed checkpoint
blockade. We found several patients had disease control.
Seven out of 11 or seven out of 10 patients did have disease control.
One had a really dramatic PR who lived for almost 12 months and went on a
family vacation. And
most of the other patients, unfortunately, the disease came back quite
rapidly.
We also found that the tumor shrinkage did very nicely correlate
with the amount of NK cell expansion in those patients.
And when we took at two time points, day 14 and day 28, we
isolated, we flow sorted their NK cells, or rather bead sorted their NK
cells, and then ran the NG to see what fraction was donor versus what
fraction was the patient's own. As expected, this
is a haploidentical donor, they will be rejected by day 28.
Although there was a small fraction of NK cells which did survive beyond day 28,
which we don't fully understand because HLA mismatch will lead to culling down of
those cells.
But then we quickly realized that you need a CAR arming because this is
not durable enough and this is not deep enough.
So one of the first foray was targeting mesothelin, as mesothelin is a very
attractive target expressed by multiple types of cancer, including
ovarian cancer. And over the years, people have developed different binders
targeting different domains of mesothelin.
We were particularly interested in the membrane proximal domain, and the reason
for that is because mesothelin gets shed, it gets clipped, and if you target
the distal domain, then there's loss of efficacy.
So we use same, we create a CAR 4-1BB based construct, a
second generation lentivirus.
We had also shown that baboon lentivirus works really well in memory-like
NK cells because memory-like NK cells have high expression of AACT1 and
2, which baboon lentivirus binds to versus, say,
VSVG, which binds to LDLR, which human NK cells don't have much
expression. So we get very nice expression
in these NK cells. Again, memory-like NK cells.
And when we looked in the ovarian PDXs, as you can see, based on the mesothelin
expression, this particular patient had no mesothelin.
You didn't see much activity versus these two patients we saw robust control.
In a xenograft mouse model, as you can see, that this CAR
worked really well. But mind you, none of those mice, none of the
mice got cured. We could not see complete eradication of tumor.
Then at the time, we said, "If you're going to go to clinic and if we can't cure
mice, there is no way
we can cure patients. So we can do better." How can we do better?
Well, one of the ginormous experiments, eight groups here, mind you, and five
mice each group, we asked, "There's so many groups trying different
cytokines. Let's do this unbiased screen of CAR
construct." Each one is secreting a given type of cytokine.
As shown here, 15, 18, 12, even IL-7 with IL-7 receptor, and
see which one wins. This is CD70 CAR, and we tested AML.
And one CAR in particular won single-handedly, and some of the
mice, around 40%, lived a really long time, was IL-12.
Telling the IL-2 in an NK cell CAR setting is really, really
important. Now,
obviously, IL-2 has been used by T cell groups.
So the problem with IL-12 with T cells is that there's autoactivation of
T cells in combination TCR engagement or CAR engagement that leads to
too much cytokine, pro-inflammatory cytokine and toxicity.
So we did a head-to-head comparison, CAR NK cells, same donor, plus/minus tumor,
and CAR T cells. As you can see, the magnitude and the breadth of cytokines,
pro-inflammatory cytokines secreted by CAR T cells was way higher
than CAR NK cells. And that explains why we have not seen severe
cytokine release syndrome or neurotoxicity with different products using CAR NK
cells. Then we alsoSo we made this single
peptide or single-chain fusion IL-12 because it has two domains, or
excuse me, two units, subunits P40 and P35, put the elastin
linker, and then we put also collagen binding domain,
which we derived from A3 domain of von Willebrand factor so that it can trap into
the collagen matrix because most solid tumors have high expression of collagen
type I and type III, and this von Willebrand factor A3 domain binds
to it. So the idea was whatever IL-12 is secreted, it gets trapped in the tumor
matrix. The idea came from Dr. Jeffrey Hubbell's
group at U Chicago, because he showed that you can do this for
different cytokines, stand-alone cytokine, they can get trapped.
So then we went back and looked at the in vitro data.
This is against the pancreatic cancer and ovarian cancer
organoids. And you can see that when we had either the regular IL-12 or with
IL-12 with A3, much better killing.
And then we also did long-term incicide assays where we showed the IL-12 CARs
actually registered exhaustion or, I know Eric doesn't
like exhaustion, so don't I, but nonetheless, registered loss of
function for a really long time.
And then when we put in vivo in a xenograft mouse model, just 1 million.
A lot of NK cell people, including myself, are
putting 10 million or more in every few weeks, which is in
immune models. And even then, we can't really cure.
So that's a problem, because imagine if you need 10 million per mouse, how many
NK cells you need for patients? So we said, if this IL-12 is
really this potent, we should see some FKC putting just
1 million total NK cells with half or 60% of them being transduced.
And this is that data, orthotopic ovarian cancer, peritoneal model, and you can
see half of those mice got cured. And when we looked at the endpoint analysis,
most of the mice had really nice expansion of NK
cells as long as they received the IL-12.
And when we looked at the-- sorry, I don't know what happened here, but
nonetheless, it's looking at the biases, the nanograms per mil.
When we looked at IL-12 expression or presence of IL-12 in the
plasma, you can see that the mice which received mesothelin CAR with
IL-12 with E3 domain, as I mentioned, it's a tumor matrix trapper.
It did actually lead to trapping of the IL-12 so that there's not systemic
exposure to IL-12. We also
did a subcutaneous model of pancreatic cancer and showed that when we give
this CAR IV, there's actually more NK cell infiltration and
more, obviously, more trapping of the IL-12 in the tumor matrix.
And obviously, you want to combine cytokine, not just cis activation, but
also bystander activation. So we combined with the same
donor T cell, in this case, CAR T cells, because you need CAR for T
cells to recognize tumor. In presence of tumor, and you can see more proliferation
and more CD107 and more interferon gamma. I apologize for this.
I don't know, it wasn't showing on the Mac like this.
But also macrophage modulation, where we saw that the
M2-like, I know we are not supposed to call M2s.
M2 anymore are pro-tumor and anti-tumor, but nonetheless, M2-like,
there was actually a drop in them by CD61 three
and more in the M1-like, which is what you want, pro-inflammatory.
So all good. We have done further work showing that the CAR
signaling goes through PI3 kinase and Erk and actually
synergizes with... Excuse me, the other way around.
IL-2 signaling synergize with CAR through mTOR pathway.
And have actually looked at the, when we put the NK cell
CAR, this IL-12 engineered with the tumor target, you saw robust
PS6 expression, and then in two
models. And we put rapamycin, it went away completely.
This paper is under review, hope to publish it soon.
But then the problem with the tumor matrix is there's so much inhibition
going on. You cannot really be naive enough that one
intervention you are doing is going to cure anyone with really bad
pancreatic cancer or small cell lung cancer.
So one of the things we are going after in my group is
TGF-beta. And as you know, TGF-beta is a really dominant
immune suppressive cytokine
in many of the solid tumors, including actually liquid tumors for
that matter. And the two ways people have gone after is either you
knock out the receptor, you can do the CRISPR knockout, or more recently, knock out
the downstream signaling, which is SMAD4, or you can put a
flip receptor, where it flips the inhibited activation.
But that does not change the TME, because yes, your given cell type,
CAR T cell, CAR macrophage, CAR NK cell, will escape the TGF-beta.
But what happens to the endogenous tumor infiltrated lymphocytes?
Unless you activate them, nothing is going to happen.
So we have
created this new
synthetic promoter based on the TGF-beta
responsive circuit, basically responsive elements.
We have screened a bunch of them, either the
SMAD binding enhancer elements, we have tried different numbers,
or the other one, which is 12CAGA. And we have
combined them with different promoters, weak and strong.
And the idea is that this NK cell CAR, in this case, or for that matter, CAR T
cell, will have this highly TGF-beta sensitive promoter.
The moment it goes in the tumor microenvironment, it sees TGF-beta, and then it
can make a gene of choice.
And we are obviously being interested in IL-12.
We said, "Okay, let's have IL-12 driven by our TGF-beta
sensor." We have made two sensors. One is a little stronger, one is less.
But nonetheless, we showed very nicely that, yes, we can drive CAR expression,
we can drive the IL-12 expression, but then the
problem is there was leakage.
Then we went back to the drawing board.
Actually, we said, "We don't have to have the
gene on the same strand." Because there are two strands of DNA, and viruses for
HIV all the time have proteins on two different strands.
And the reason for this is because 5 LTR, even with the
later generation of antivirus, we still got leakage.
So we actually took on the reverse strand, this TGF-beta sensor, which
was completely then away from any interference from the 5 LTR,
and the leakage went completely away.
And this is the data showing the both CAR T cells and CAR NK cells.
We have very little to no leakage, meaning when you don't have TGF-beta in
the media, not much gets produced.Then we went back,
okay, let's try it in the in vivo mouse models.
Although it's actually kidney cancer because we chose the CD17.
Now we have tried in other models as well.
I'm just showing CD17 CAR, and you can still see that it's not enough.
When you have TJBbeta, even though it produces IL-12, it's still not enough.
And in vivo you can see still these mice end up all relapsing.
So that's a problem. Then we said, if this is true that we can drive IL-12, what
about we combine another cytokine?
And the most potent synergy between cytokines with IL-12 is
IL-18. That's well known, especially in NK cells.
Now, you wouldn't in your wildest dreams dare to combine IL-12 and
18. It's like putting PMA ionomycin.
It's almost as strong as that to produce all sorts of things.
It's almost always used as a positive control in vitro when you, for example, need
interferon gamma. But because of the sensor, we hypothesized, since
IL-12 has a A3 domain, it will get stuck in the tumor matrix, and
IL-18, people have shown is safe, why can't we drive it?
So we made this TJBbeta sensor on the reverse strand, driving
IL-12 with A3 matrix, and the forward strand, we put
IL-18 with mutine, which doesn't get bound by
the IL-18 binding peptide. So then we went back and looked into whether
that's true, whether it can actually work on the suppression, and it does seem to
work on the suppression, as shown here against, I believe this is the
kidney cancer model.
Then we went in vivo. This is the, again, kidney cancer subcutaneous
model, 2 million CAR NK cells. I have never seen anything work this
good. Not only was it safe, but we actually seem to have cured almost all
mice which received this dual cytokine TJBbeta sensor
including promoter. And then obviously, at endpoint time
analysis we did, and we saw very robust expansion and
activation of NK cells in major organs, which was a nice thing.
And then we also, since you can ask, well, this is
xenograft, what about the murine models?
One of the fundamental problems in the CAR NK cell field is we don't
have ability to create murine NK cells.
Now, that may be changing with lipid nanoparticles and mRNA, but as of now, that's
a problem. So we said, okay, if this is safe in CAR T
cells, it better be safe in CAR NK. So we went back to the drawing board and put in
the CAR T cells using mesothelin CAR, which on its own has some toxicity,
and this is the subcu model of KPC-2, which is an highly aggressive
pancreatic cancer, and yet we are curing half of the mice.
And it's completely safe. And we have now cytokine analysis and
endpoint organ analysis showing that they are really, really safe, not
causing any tox. So this gives us confidence that this product is safe and this
can go to clinic. So we're working with AML group and
kidney cancer group to take to clinic. One last thing.
Few more slides, promise.
My group is also very interested in engineering bacteria to deliver
biologics and to TME. And the reason is that more and more
realization that most solid tumors, like this nice
paper from Leiden group, have a microbiome.
Typically, we think of microbiome in the gut and skin, but there's more
realization, actually, most tumors have their own microbiome.
And a very outstanding PhD student in my lab who's now a postdoc, Shaobo Yang,
came with the idea that can we engineer this bacteria if they really like to go to
the tumor microenvironment and deliver all sorts of things.
And this sounds crazy, but there have been trials.
People have injected bacteria, including this trial from Steven Rosenberg,
IV Salmonella, and shown this is safe.
So, this is a paper we published last year where we took the K12
DH5alpha, which is extremely safe, dumbed down version of
E. coli derived from gut microbiome from a patient,
and it's a phage to N robe. We did a bunch of engineering.
We're able to express both murine and human cytokines, shown here the
list. And when we put systemically,
again, systemically into the mice bearing MC38 with
PD-1 block, and we cured more than half of those mice.
And with recall, none of those mice came back.
We also looked where are they going?
And actually, they are going mostly toward the center of the tumor, as shown here.
And what are the cells which are
really triggering this response?
Primarily CD8 and some activity mediated through NK cells.
Granulocytes go up, but when we did the depletion study, granulocytes had no
impact. And how long they last in the tumors?
So this is a tumor enrichment at day seven.
As you can see, around 10,000-fold enrichment.
By day 10, all the organs are cleared, but you still see tumor having these
bacteria. By day 14, they are clear.
So we think around
10 to 12 days.
We also combine the CAR NK cells, ideas that will,
CAR NK cells don't like as well going into the solid tumors.
So can we combine these TME changing bacteria, if you
will, and can they synergize with CAR NK cells?
And we took a really, really refractory model using mesothelioma
H226, which is highly dense and does not have much vasculature.
As you can see, when we combine, there was a complete flattening of growth, and
when we took down the tumors, there was increased infiltration of CAR NK cells when
we combined with the bacteria. And when we did the RNAseq, we found that it's
mediated by TNF alpha signaling via NFKB, which we think represents TLR
signaling and IL-18 signaling.
Lastly,
recently, there's a
very outstanding MD PhD postdoc from
Germany,
Essen University, who wanted to express IL-12 in our bacteria,
and she was successfully able to engineer this big bacteria expressing IL-12,
and shown that in vitro we can have enhanced NK cell function
when we co-cultured this E. coli expressing IL-12 with NK
cells, human NK cells, and murine NK cells, this is the human data here, and
shown that they work really well. But the problem was, and I'm glad Eric showed
some of the data on ENTPD1, which is a CD39,
we found that when we characterized those NK cells, several members of the
adenosine pathway, including CD39, got upregulated. So there's a break.
So the moment this bacteria get co-cultured with NK cells, primarily driven
by bacteria, they get their several members up on the adenosine
pathway. Then we went back. Can we do better?
So we then engineer this bacteria to express adenosine deaminase on top of
IL-12, because remember, there are some kids who are born with adenosine deaminase
deficiency, ADA kids, and the treatment is every abroad
ADA infusion. So we created this bacteria which have both IL-12 and
adenosine deaminase, and there's the structure, and they work really well.
And we recently combined this bacteria with pancreatic cancer CAR,
CAR target pancreatic mesothelin CAR.
And as you can see, we doubled the survival in these mice.
And when we took down the tumors, we found that there was more CAR infiltration
into those tumors when we had IL-12. That's all I have.
I would like to thank my lab members as well as collaborators, some of whom are
here, and thank you for inviting me.
Yes. Let's show this mic is working. Hello?
Thank you very much, Rizwan, for this very nice presentation.
Any question in the room? There are many questions, actually.
I forgot the questions to me actually as well, but that's okay.
I'll take them online if people want to send me emails.
I will be happy to answer all these questions.
But for you, for Rizwan, any questions?
You should come up to the mic.
Yeah.
Hi.
I was just wondering if you expect any
problems that may occur due to the tumor microenvironment
that can affect
the
efficiency of the cells that you make.
The whole point of using the TGF-beta sensor was to take
advantage of the immunosuppressive TME, so that the
immunosuppressive TME with high TGF-beta, and as I said, that many
tumors have high TGF-beta in the tumor microenvironment, to trigger
expression of IL-12 and 18. 18 is constitutive, but IL-12.
So that was the whole point, that we are able to flip the tumor
on its head, make it inhibition to activation, and
that IL-12 and 18 is such a potent combo that that can
activate T cells and NK cells and innate
lymphoid cells and other macrophages in the tumor microenvironment.
But yes, absolutely, and that's the
immune competent mouse model, where we have all the elements.
That's the stuff we are looking at right now.
Sounds very promising.
Thank you.
Okay, so we have questions in the chat, and I have a question myself.
Maybe I will start by my own question.
Yes.
Can you please tell us more about the tissue distribution of the
bacteria when you inject them? Because do they go preferentially
to the tumor? And if yes, how come, or not?
Yeah, no, this is a million dollar, probably a billion dollar question.
But
we think, our hypothesis currently is that when we inject this bacteria, they go
pretty much everywhere. They are in the circulation. They don't know where to go.
Yes, they have flagella, they have chemotaxis, but they make it to all
the major organs. Now, what happens in the TME,
when the blood vessels are floating through the
tumor, there's high lactate, there's hypoxemia,
and they love it. And that's where they
start chemotaxis and go into the TME and thrive there.
Everywhere else, they get cleared to begin with, and if they do
it, they don't survive because the environment is so hostile.
So normal liver or normal organ, where there's macrophages and neutrophils and
other immune cells, they will just cull them down.
But the TME is so immune suppressed, and the fact that we have high lactate
and low oxygen and low glucose, that's where these bacteria
shine. We are doing a
CRISPR screen on this bacteria currently, and we are trying to
figure out whether we can enhance and figure out what genes are
critical in those
bacteria to home better in the tumor microenvironment.
But did you have a chance, to follow up on this question, to measure the
PK of whatever cytokine you add to your bacteria to find
out whether that should be improved or not?
Yeah. A lot of work happening in multiple cytokines currently.
In the previous paper we published, it seemed to peak
between day three and day seven. Afterwards, there was a decline,
but it may also vary from cytokine to cytokine.
For example, we just ran a study using IL-12 bacteria in
AML, in immune competent AML model, where these bacteria are
going to bone marrow. We did not expect, but turns out bone marrow is
hypoxemic to begin with, and especially AML and tumor-bearing
bone marrow is very hypoxemic. So they seem to go within two hours,
and we have done a peak, kind of a PK, where this initial burst happens
within hours, and then they decline.
Okay. So two questions from the chat.
The first one, could you describe the in vivo model used for the
CAR-NK with IL-12?
I'm sorry, in vivo use?
Can you describe the in vivo model that you use for the CAR-NK
with IL-12?
Yeah. So this is a paper. Hopefully, it should come in one of the ACR journals.
I'm excited about that. It's undergoing revision.
And
we have done both ovarian cancer as well as pancreatic
cancer, and more recently, AML models.
And all the three models, the IL-12
works really well
standalone. But more recently, we have now added TGF-beta sensor
IL-18, we seem to even more turbocharge it.
Okay, another question. Can you tell more about baboon vector?
Why does it help in transducing specific memory in K cells?
Do you use this platform for all the complex vector designs?
Yes, for the most part. So this is a collaboration with MIT group.
Professor Andrew Chen, a few years back, we published a PNAS paper in 2022,
where we found that the memory-like NK cells have increased
expression of AACT1 and 2, which is the binding
receptor on
cells, including NK cells, for the baboon
serotype lentivirus. Versus a VSVG, it binds to the
LDLR. Now, you can take RD114, and
RD114 also binds to AACT1 and 2. And we have actually
optimized gamma retrovirus, which almost mimics the same
functionality. But it's a little bit more finicky.
You have to really optimize the product.
But the baboon works beautifully, and
that's what we hope to take to clinic in coming years.
Okay. Last question for you.
Okay, there's this thing going here.
Do you think TGF-beta suppression in your system
primarily acts as a level of proximal signaling in CAR-NK
cells, or is it mainly due to
downstream transcriptional reprogramming?
So we think it's primarily from the first one, which is basically it triggers
our sensor. Now, of course, there are downstream pathway we do not
knock out. For example, the SMAD4, we do not knock out in our
sensor expressing CAR because we are relying on SMAD4
dimerization or trimerization, I think it's dimerization, to go and bind to the
promoter. The promoter just has more enhancer binders
for the SMADs, so that they're more centered than the
endogenous proteins. So we are kind of taking away this
complex, and our own gene of choice gets more expressed based
on the enhanced affinity. And when we did the library, that was the idea, how
many enhancer elements to put in to make it optimal.
As a matter of fact, the next speaker, Dr.
Tim Lu, has done pioneering work in creating synthetic promoters.
I highly recommend referring to his paper in 2018, I think
they wrote in "Cell," where they did similar work, not with TJPAB but the idea is
very similar. They can create synthetic promoters, and you can modify the
enhancer binding elements, and you can play with them in terms of number of
elements and what elements with what promoter to create a given
sensor, essentially. And that's what essentially we did, except for TJPAB.
Okay, thanks a lot, Rizwan.
Thank you.
Thanks a lot.
So nice transition
to Tim Lu from Senti Bioscience,
who will tell us about new cells to fight cancer.
Great.
Thanks.
All right. Well, it's an honor to be here. My name is Tim.
I was previously at MIT, and I left a few years ago to try to take some of these
programs into the clinic. So I'm really excited to tell you today about what we've
been doing at Senti Bio.
Senti Bio is a biotech company based in the San Francisco Bay Area.
So what Senti has been working on is developing a class of
technologies for more precise cancer targeting, and we call
these technologies logic gates. So the idea is, can you take a cell
and program it to recognize and kill cancer cells more specifically, and at
the same time, recognize healthy cells and protect those healthy cells from being
killed?
We've developed this logic gate technology for the last few years, and now have
advanced it into clinical studies.
Our lead program is called SENTI-202, where we've used this logic gate
technology to engineer an off-the-shelf allogeneic NK
product to treat relapse/refractory AML.
Some of the benefits of the logic gating technology is that it allows you to go
after cancers for which there are no clean, single targets available.
We spent many, many years in the field looking for targets that are only on the
cancer cells and minimally expressed on healthy cells.
There's probably only so many of those that are out there.
But if we can use this technology to program cells to recognize multiple
targets and then make a decision on what to kill and what not to kill, perhaps we
can expand the types of indications we can go after.
We were very excited to present back in December at ASH, our results from
our Phase I clinical study in relapse/refractory AML,
where we saw durable responses with a 50%
ORR rate, about 40% CR/CR rate.
One of the nice things about this product is we saw actually evidence of high MRD
negative rates as well,
and a very good safety profile consistent with many of the NK studies that
previous speakers reported on. I'm going to show you some data also confirming the
MOA of the product, where you can see selective killing of these AML blasts
and leukemic stem cells, along with sparing of the healthy bone marrow stem
cells. So this program did have the fortune of being
designated with RMAT last year, which gives us some opportunity to interact with
the FDA more frequently to try to move this program forward, and our plan is to
launch into a pivotal study later this year.
We also have a lot of intention to actually use this logic gate technology in other
cancers, including in solid tumors.
So we are focused initially on AML.
We think it's a place where NK's have been tried quite a lot, and we think there's
opportunities to really bring something new to the treatment of patients with
AML. Relapse/refractory AML is our initial focus, although we have
an opportunity, I think, and a lot of clinical interest to move this into the newly
diagnosed space, which is what our plan is.
And certainly, as I mentioned earlier, solid tumor is an area that we are very
excited to try to push forward into. All right.
So let me tell you a little bit about the underlying genetic technology that we
developed here at Senti. I'm going to focus today primarily on this idea of logic
gating. Essentially, what we're doing is building combinations of CAR
receptors. So on one hand, we can build activating CARs that
recognize multiple cancer antigens and trigger killing.
On the other hand, we can build inhibitory CAR receptors, which is what that purple
receptor is supposed to represent.
And what that inhibitory receptor does is it can recognize healthy targets,
so targets that are highly expressed on healthy cells, but not on cancer cells and
provide a do not kill type of signal.
This requires a lot of optimization because you have to balance the two arms of the
CARs, right? If you have an activating CAR that's too strong, you're going to
trigger killing, and you can't shut it off.
If the inhibitory CAR is too strong, you might just make the cells energenic,
and they can't do anything. So you have to balance the two, and there's a lot of
engineering that goes behind that.
We do have other technologies that I won't have time to really go through today.
We are,
like Dr. Ramy mentioned, very excited about the idea of multi-arming cells.
We also believe in the need to control
these multi-arming constructs. So using, for example, small molecule regulators or,
for example, some of the synthetic promoters that were mentioned earlier to try to
regulate when and how much of these
constructs are being expressed, we think are very important.
So why logic gates, right? So if we think about developing a cell therapy, cell
therapies are inherently, at least at this stage in time, more complex than a
biologic drug. So we want to go after diseases for which there's no
direct biologic competition, right?
It's oftentimes, from a pharma perspective, easier just to make a protein
than it is to make a cell. It turns out there are many, many efforts to try to
develop, as everyone here knows, ADCs, T-cell engagers, et cetera, against
those targets that have been well-recognized to be clean
enough to essentially enable that sort of approach.
But if you can't find such a clean target, one of the risks you see is that you
have this on-target, off-tumor killing that makes it difficult to find a
therapeutic window. So we want to go after cancers for which there are no clean
targets that are available, but by combining two or three targets
togetherThat signature or that panel can give you the specificity that you
want.
So we are doing this for AML, and that's what today I'm going to focus on today.
So there's a high unmet need in patients with relapsed refractory AML.
This is a chart here on the left side from Blood, sort of indicating the general
sort of a matrix by which relapsed refractory AML is treated.
In general, like many physicians are actually looking for a clinical trial because
they recognize that many of the existing drugs, even if they're approved, are not
giving great responses. Number two is patients can be eligible for an
allogeneic HCT, and depending on whether the answer is yes or no, you
can qualify for a stem cell transplant.
However, to get to that stem cell transplant, you need to be able to clear enough
of the disease so that the patient can go through that process.
In general, patients can get things like salvage chemotherapy, plus or minus
venetoclax. There are targeted therapies that are approved.
But unfortunately, if you don't have some of those mutations, you may not be
eligible for those.
Right now, relapsed refractory AML patients have relatively
sort of poorer prognosis, unfortunately, with CR rates in the 15% to
20% range, CRch rates in the 20% to 30% range, and the
median survival is about five months.
There's a couple of interesting criterias that also make AML a good test case for
this LogicGate technology. It turns out in AML, responses require two
major things to happen. So in the middle category here, you have to be able to kill
the AML blasts. So you have to get the AML blast count below 5%.
There's this added sort of measurement that people are starting to do around using
MRD detection to see if you can get down to a sensitivity of 10 to
minus three or 10 to minus four in terms of determining have I killed the AML
cells. But there's a second category that's very important, which is looking
at peripheral blood counts, and that's really intimately tied in with, number one,
are you clearing the cancer? But two, are you able to protect the healthy cells,
including the healthy stem cells, from being killed?
So there's criteria like looking at the neutrophil counts and the platelet counts,
and if they're above a certain threshold, we call that a CR.
If there are intermediate recoveries, those are CRhs and CRIs.
And MLFS is a category of patients that have responded in terms
of absence of detectable cancer cells.
However, the peripheral blood counts have not fully recovered.
So this is important to us because the way we design this product is to try to kill
the cancer cells, to go after both the AML blasts and the AML
leukemic stem cells, which are important in disease, but at the same time, to spare
the healthy hematopoietic stem cells from being killed.
And so what's the reason why we need that in this disease?
It turns out that many of the targets that people are very excited about in AML are
not only expressed on the AML cells, but they're also expressed on some
population of healthy blood cells, including sometimes the healthy stem cells.
And so if you hit the cancer cells too hard, you may
cause a toxicity to the bone marrow.
So the way we can try to solve this problem is through this concept of the
activating and inhibitory CAR, that LogicGate I'm talking about.
So what we did here was to design an activating CAR to go after two different
targets that are well-known in the space. These are CD33 and FLT3.
These were chosen through a pretty
wide bioinformatic search that we did to look at combinations of targets that might
go well together. CD33 is very well expressed on AML blasts,
has some expression on leukemic stem cells, and FLT3 has good expression on
leukemic stem cells as well. So by putting them together, we think we can more
broadly and perhaps deeply kill both those cell populations.
Now it turns out, especially for FLT3, FLT3 has a problem that it's expressed on
healthy bone marrow stem cells, including the hematopoietic stem cell.
And so to try to protect those cells from being killed, we did a bioinformatic
search to look for targets that were expressed on the healthy cells but have low
expression on the cancer cells. And there happened to be a list of about seven
targets that came out of that search that were on the cell surface that we could
address. We went through a whole design process to try to pick out which ones we
want to go after and selected this target called EMCN or endomucin.
So endomucin is this target that's got this inverse expression.
It's high on this particular population of healthy cells and low on the cancer
cells. And what we did was design an inhibitory CAR to
recognize that particular target and to shut down the killing activity.
There's a lot of underlying protein engineering that I'm not going to go through
here in detail, but getting these two receptors to be balanced was very important.
Now, the third element here is an IL-15 molecule that we put into the cells to
enhance the activity. Now, given that this is an NK panel, one might ask,
does this technology work only in NK cells, or can we get it to work in other cell
types, and why did we choose NK cells here?
We do have the LogicGate technology working in both NK cells and T cells.
And our perspective is we choose the cell type that we think will be best fitted
for that particular clinical population.
In AML, one of the challenges for autologous T cells is that oftentimes these
patients may not have
been through multiple rounds of treatment.
Chemotherapy can be toxic to those cells, and even the disease itself may cause T
cell dysfunction. So getting high-quality autologous CAR T
from these patients made and delivered back to these patients, which can take a
month or more, is a major challenge.
In contrast, NK cells, we can make off the shelf from healthy donors.
We've developed a very scalable GMP process that allows us to manufacture and
freeze the cells, and then we can ship the cells out the next day to be used in
patients. So we think the NK chassis makes a lot of sense.
In addition to that, there's a lot of clinical literature on the use of natural NK
cells in the past in humans to try to treat diseases like AML.
So like I mentioned, we have a 14-day manufacturing process.
We do get healthy blood from
selected donors. We do some donor characteristic testing to make sure
that we are getting samples, and then we can repeatedly get samples from these
donors that give us high-quality NK cells, both in terms of ability to get the
cells to expand, but also to maintain high cytotoxicity.
We use an engineering step. We're using a retrovirus, to deliver the genetic
circuit. It has three different genes that are encoded on a single virus into the
cells. We can expand the cells further, and then importantly, we spend a lot of
time doing cryopreservation to try to preserve the NK cells and make sure they're
stable so that upon delivery to the clinical site, it's a simple thaw and infuse
step.The clinical trial currently has been carried out in
the US as well as in Australia. So we've been able to ship these cells around the
country, also over to Australia as well for delivery.
The Phase 1 clinical trial was designed to go after adult
patients with relapsed refractory AML that expressed either CD33
or FLT3. It turns out in AML, CD33 is one of the
diagnostic criteria or in the diagnostic panel, so all of our patients come in
CD33 positive by clinical site, and then we have some
data around some patients that are FLT3 positive, some patients that have
intermediate FLT3 expression.
We started off the Phase 1 clinical study through a dose-finding to look at
different schedules of dosing as well as dose escalation, also looking at efficacy
at the same time.
So generally, the protocol was for looking at
this product was to, on the upper left-hand side, look at two different dosing
schedules. We start out with a lymphodepletion step, like with other cell
therapies. In this case, we are using fludarabine and cytarabine, which is an
AML-specific regimen. We tested two different
dosing schedules in each cycle. The schedule one was once
every week, so 0, 7, 14. Schedule two was every three or four
days. So day 0, 3, 7, 10, 14. So five doses total.
In both cases, we assess for response at 28 days.
Patients can get up to four cycles, although as you'll see in the Phase 1 study,
patients generally got one or two cycles at most.
We did do dose-finding and looked at either one billion CAR positive NK cells per
dose or 1.5 billion. Ended up going with schedule one.
It's much more convenient for patients.
We do want this to be accessible for delivery in infusion
centers and even be used in potentially outpatient settings.
And we didn't see any reduced efficacy with schedule one.
We did use the dose level two. We did see some benefits with that particular
approach.
This trial did enroll patients with multiple baseline adverse risk
characteristics and poor prognosis, especially in the dose level two category in
these AML patients. We had many patients that actually came with
baseline low neutrophil counts and low platelet counts.
Those are typically signs that the patient is not in great shape because the
disease is somehow causing bone marrow dysfunction in these
patients. Majority of patients were also diagnosed as adverse
risk by ELN 2022, which is a diagnostic criteria for stratifying
patients. These patients were heavily pre-treated.
One of the criteria is that these patients had to go anywhere between one to
three prior lines of treatment. If they were eligible for a TARID
inhibitor, they must have received it and failed it to come on.
And so you can see that in general, all of our patients received chemotherapy,
including prior exposure to fludarabine and cytarabine.
Most patients received venetoclax, hypomethylating agents, and many
patients actually had prior stem cell transplants and relapsed.
Also, in the RPTD cohort, a majority of patients were actually refractory to their
most recent regimen, which means that the last thing that they tried essentially
didn't work for over less than three months.
I mentioned most patients got one or two cycles.
In general, nobody discontinued treatment due to adverse events.
The reason why in some cases we had patients get one cycle is we got them into an
MRD negative CR. Physicians got really excited and took them to transplant.
In general, in terms of overall adverse events, majority of the
adverse events were essentially attributed not to 202, but to some other element of
the protocol, including lymphodepletion.
As we know, lymphodepletion, that can reduce your blood counts, and we did
see some patients that were reported to have febrile neutropenia, low platelet
counts, anemia, or thrombocytopenia.
These are AEs that typically AML docs are very well suited to try to treat and were
not directly generally attributed to SENTI 202.
In terms of 202-related AEs, this is, I think, very consistent with prior NK
clinical studies. NK cells tend to be very safe.
They don't generate the same level of CRS that you see with CAR T cells.
Generally what we saw was Grade 1, 2 pyrexia, well managed with standard of care.
We looked at a whole panel of cytokines.
The upper right-hand corner here just takes a snapshot.
But if we look at, for example, IL-6 production, we are way lower than what you
typically see with a CAR T cell. And we think this is one of the reasons, as
mentioned earlier, that NK cells can give you a much better safety profile compared
to T cell-based products. We're excited to see that about
50% of our patients achieved an overall response with a
CR/CRh rate in the 30% to 40% range, depending on which patient cohort we looked
at. One of the things that stood out to us in this trial was that a
lot of patients, vast majority of patients, whether you were CR, CRh, or even
MLFS, did get into MRD negative status, which was very
exciting to see. That potentially can correlate with better responses.
We had a median duration of composite CRs about 7.6 months,
which again, compares favorably to other drugs in this patient
population.
So in general, this is the graph from the top.
All the responders are on the top. This data is actually from October, so these
patients, we do have updates that we'll share later this year.
We had several patients that have survived for close to two years now.
And we're excited to see many of these patients.
Some of them go to transplant, as mentioned earlier.
Doctors are consolidating with that, although that's not necessarily required by
the protocol per se. And we do envision as we go into the pivotal trial, we'll
enroll sort of a broader cohort of patients, some that are transplant eligible,
some that are transplant ineligible, and we'll be able to take a look at the
differences here.
Just to get into the MOA in a little bit more detail, we worked with MD
Anderson, where we sent all our patient samples there, and they actually did CyTOF
analysis to look at specific subsets of cells in the patient bone marrows.
So we looked at initially the cancer cells, so the AML blasts and AML leukemic stem
cells. On the left-hand side, we first looked at the leukemic stem cell population.
It turns out the majority of these cells are in that G0 quiescent state,
very difficult to kill with conventional chemotherapy, and that's really consistent
with prior literature describing this cell population.
We were very excited to see on the right-hand side actually that with treatment,
especially obviously for those patients that responded, we saw a significant
reduction in these LSCs with treatment, sometimes more than tenfold
or 100-fold, even higher than that,
giving us some evidence that we are killing those LSCs directly.
We also see very significant reductions in AML blasts in our responders in the
middle here.
Some patients even coming in with over 90% bone marrow blast at
baseline.Now, the flip side of this is we want to be able to see we're not killing
the hematopoietic stem cell. So we did the same CyTOF analysis, right, and looked
at healthy
samples at the same time. On the right-hand side, the interesting thing is, in
general, we see compared from baseline to after cycle one or cycle two,
a maintenance or enrichment of the hematopoietic stem cell
population, which is exciting to see.
The left-hand side actually shows
an interesting finding. We had some patients that did generate a
CR/CRh response. Remember I mentioned earlier that response requires some of your
healthy cells to recover. We also had a couple of patients that actually had an
MLFS response. Again, that response criteria is patients who have
reduction in tumor counts or undetectable levels of remaining AML
cells, but you don't get that full recovery.
You don't even get partial recovery of their healthy cell.
And it turns out that those two patients came onto the study with basically
undetectable levels of hematopoietic stem cells
in the CyTOF analysis. So it does suggest to us perhaps that if patients are coming
on with poor bone marrow function, you can't rescue something that's not there.
But perhaps as we try to push this product into earlier lines of therapy, even
to newly diagnosed AML, we hope we'll see more patients derive benefit from the
Logic Gate technology.
The last thing I'll show you from the clinical data here is that in terms of
platelet counts and neutrophils, you can see, from day minus seven to day zero,
where you have that lymphodepletion, that's where you see the drops in the
platelets and the neutrophils. We do have treatment with the product in about 14
days, from day zero to day 14, and you see a pretty strong recovery, actually, of
platelets and neutrophils in those responders, indicating that these cells
aren't causing overt bone marrow toxicity, and perhaps by treating the
cancer, we're creating the ability for the repopulation of these healthy cells.
So we're really excited to see that for these patients.
I lied to you. There's one more piece of data. There is PK data here.
Generally, we're seeing about 14 to 21 days
post-lymphodepletion. I think that's what is expected for allogeneic cell therapy
of this type. We aren't doing any specific editing at this point to try to remove
factors that might improve
the allo
lifespan, although that's something you can certainly think of for a next
generation product.
So we're very excited about where SENTI 202 is, and we think it demonstrates
preliminary promising efficacy.
I guess this is just a summary, so I'll skip forward just because of time.
Our plan for this year is to have that next stage interaction with the FDA.
We do have RMAT status, and we want to get alignment with the FDA on what the plan
is to move this into the pivotal study.
There were some recent approvals in the
relapsed/refractory AML space with single-arm studies with breakthrough
status given. We think there's a great opportunity for these cells, especially if
we can maintain this type of response rate and the deep MRD negative
type responses for this program to move into a pivotal study.
So that's really what we're focused on at the same time of upgrading our
manufacturing to be ready for that pivotal.
The last thing I'll show you is just some videos because I think it's kind of
exciting to see these logic gates actually in action.
We have been developing logic gates that can be applied to solid tumors, including
targets like CEA,
where CEA is expressed not just on cancer cells, but it has expression on healthy
colon cells, for example. So we went through the same discovery process and
identified a healthy target, in this case called VSIG2, that can
protect healthy cells from being killed.
We have put this into both NK cells and T cells, and these are microscopy images
that showcase how we do the development here internally.
So for the first example, we've mixed the cancer cells in red and the healthy cells
in green. The healthy cells and cancer cells both express CEA.
The only difference is the green cells express VSIG2 also.
And you can see with no NK cells, both these cell populations grow.
With CEA only targeted NK cells, you kill both.
And with the CEA not VSIG2, you can basically kill the cancer cells and spare the
healthy ones.
I will say that we've done this for T cells as well.
So, we have this technology working across different cell types.
We use slightly different protein domains to get it to work in T cells versus NK
cells, but in general, the principle is the same.
So with that, I think I'm on time. I would like to thank you for your time.
Happy to take any questions and yeah, appreciate the opportunity. Thank you.
Yes. Question, exactly on time.
Very thoughtful and interesting concept.
Thank you for this clear presentation.
Could you elaborate
a little bit more on how you secure
that your CAR engineer cells can
bind when only two or three anchor are being expressed
and not when there is only one?
Are there any kind of engineering being- Yeah ...
made on the receptor? So we're not
relying on binding per se. It's really the signaling that's giving us
this logic gating capability. So the way this logic gate works
is the intracellular signals for the activating CAR.
These are, everyone knows CD28zeta, 4-1BBzeta.
These are activating signals, and we have found inhibitory domains that basically
block those signaling events. So the idea here is not that
we're preventing the cells from binding, like healthy cells or cancer cells,
it's the sort of sum of the positive and negative signals that determines
what the cell does. And I guess going back to interesting NK biology, you
probably know NK cells do that naturally, right?
There's a battery of activating and inhibitory receptors, and it's kind of like a
summation of the two that give you a determination of what it's going to do, and
we're basically replicating that in a synthetic setting. Okay. Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Congratulations. Very nice-
Thank you ... findings. One thing is when you just give for
relapsed/refractory AML, just the NK cells by
themselves, you also get up to 40% remissions. Yeah.
How do you distinguish what is really an effect of the CAR and what- Yeah ...
is the NK cell activity by itself? Yeah, it's a great question.
So I think we have seen studies where you can get responses with native NK cells.
Typically, in those studies, the durability of those responses are pretty low.
And so one of the things that we're doing with this particular product is trying to
demonstrate that we can get deep MRD negative responses that last longer.
That is also one of the reasons why we went in and actually did this study with the
CyTOF analysis to show that we are getting target-specific killing.
Many of those studies, as far as I know, are single studies, single sites,
and we are trying to do this. This clinical study was done across six different
clinical centers, and our goal, hopefully, is to have a good
package around 20, 30 sites that are doing this.
And this is hopefully also an off-the-shelf frozen product as well.
Thank you.
Okay, we have questions from the chat.
Maybe I'll start with this. There are questions about the
selection criteria for the donors.
Yeah.
You mentioned that you were selecting donors, so please let us know.
There is some criteria that we haven't publicly described, but I think essentially
what we're looking for when you are manufacturing these cells, there's sort of a
trade-off between how well the cells expand and how well the cells kill.
And you kind of want to find a balance between the two.
So initially we did a lot of phenotypic work to try to screen for donors, and we
can recall these donors and bring them back in-
Yeah
... to give us more product. But there are certain sort of features,
markers that we've been able to identify that we're using more commonly now. Yeah.
But we haven't disclosed those publicly, sorry.
Okay. No, no worries.
Yeah.
Let me ask a question that I have myself.
I have a question.
You didn't tell us about the inhibitory... Oh, okay. Go ahead.
May I ask?
Go ahead.
Sure.
I have a question about the conditioning.
Do you think that the conditioning is necessary for your product?
It's a great question. Given that there's only
limited resources, we went in with using conditioning that many others have
tried. In cell therapy in general, everyone is using conditioning sort of,
quote-unquote, "clear space." Whether you can get away from that, I know other
companies are looking at reduced intensity conditioning for both NK and T
cells to see if they can get away with that.
So we haven't tried that ourselves, so it's hard to know.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thanks. Yeah, so coming back to the other questions.
You didn't tell us much about the inhibitory domain that you are
using.
Yeah.
Did you disclose this somewhere?
So we recently published a paper, I think just a few weeks ago, describing the
use of LIR-1 as one of the examples.
LIR-1?
Yeah. As an example.
So an ITIM.
Yeah. Yeah. Basically, these are combinations of ITIMs that
are enabling this to work.
I would say that we've done a lot of work not just to use the native receptor, like
we've taken domains and made mix-and-match combinations.
Behind all this, what I'm not showing is we've developed screens where you can
screen hundreds of thousands of combinations to find the best pairs.
So I think you can generally see, using PD-1 or LIR-1,
using the native intracellular ITIMs, some of this type of behavior, but if you
really want to optimize this, there's quite a lot of protein engineering you need
to do.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's known in the field that there are
problems to freeze and thaw NK cells-
Yes
... with good fitness, so-
Yeah
... how did you manage?
I know that was one of actually the things that took a long time for this to bring
this into the clinic. I think the CMC team tried a lot
of protocols to try to get something to work, and we managed to get something that
seems to give us 80%, 90% viability post-thaw.
So we're very excited about that. Again, we haven't revealed what the protocol is
specifically, but yeah, that probably was the biggest hurdle other than engineering
the receptor pair combinations.
Okay.
I was surprised how hard that was.
Let me check. Yes. So
there's another question. Has LogicGate from Senti been tried
for solid tumors? And what could be the challenge in solid tumors?
Yeah, we do have solid tumor programs. They haven't gone into the clinic yet.
Okay.
We're hoping we are able to push some of those programs into the clinic.
I think for me, the biggest concern right now is really still around tumor
heterogeneity. How many targets do you have to go after to cover
enough of the cancer to avoid escape?
It's not clear to me whether one is enough, two is enough, you need more than that.
So even if we could build the world's best LogicGate for solid tumors,
how many sort of cancer targets you need to put onto it is one big
question. And the second one is, obviously, as we heard in the previous
presentation, that tumor microenvironment, overcoming that.
LogicGate is really only solving the tumor recognition part of it.
Okay.
It's not really addressing, at this point, how do you overcome immunosuppression.
Another question about the subset of AML.
Do you know whether you have some AML subset that respond better to the
Senti asset rather than others?
It's a good question. It's something we're going to look at more in the pivotal
study. I think we looked at a variety of features in the...
But we only had about 20 patients, so it was really hard to get statistically
significant insights into that. We have also looked at whether
expression levels of particular targets correlate with
response. I would say there's some hints that it might, as you'd
expect, but we don't have enough power to statistically say that's true.
Okay, I think that we've-- Oh, another question. Thanks.
Yeah.
I have a very quick question. Thanks for the great presentation.
Thank you.
With the AML basically relapsing
due to the subclonal evolution expansion, how do you achieve a
durable immune surveillance
given the fact that NK cells, they expand and they survive, expand
for 15 days, and then they getting cleared?
Yeah. It's a good question. Look, I think what we're trying to do here is try to
drive as deep of a response, get to MRD negative in AML as we can, which
we know can correlate with better responses.
Whether or not that translates into a cure for life is another question,
right? I would say that in the current clinical trials, once we've achieved
some sort of MRD negative response, most physicians are excited enough to go to
transplant and try to, at least for now, bring benefit to the patients.
It is a long-term question on whether a cell therapy like an allo cell therapy in
this current design is going to give you that without transplant.
It's something we're going to look at. Yeah.
Okay. I think the last question is for everybody, including
you, Rizwan.
The question is,
brain and muscles tissue have highest amount of lactate.
What happen in this context with the bacterium delivery
therapy? Go ahead.
That's a good question.
It's a great question. Can you repeat it?
So-
Yes.
Sorry.
Brain and muscle tissue have highest amount of lactate.
Yep.
What happen in this context with the bacterium-directed
therapy?
Yeah, no. Part of the first paper in "Nature Biotech," it's in the
supplemental data. We did actually very in-depth analysis of muscle, heart muscle
in particular, as well as brain, and we did not see much enrichment
in those areas. So we do think that it's not just the
lactate, it's beyond that. But yes, this morning after run, my lactate
level did go up, and I do think about these things.
So yeah, we have not seen that the endogenous lactate is enough to
trigger bacterial proliferation.
I think this is the facultative anaerobe, and the fact that the immune system
is different and the chemotaxis. That's why I mentioned it's not just
making to the blood vasculature of the tumor, but also what kind of vasculature,
because tumor versus healthy, leaky versus not, and the immune
microenvironment in the tumor is so immunosuppressed that bacteria thrive very
well. Other tissues like liver, we have seen some initial burst,
but they get cleared very quickly.
Okay.
Thank you.
I think this close the session. Thank you everybody for being here.
Thanks to the speakers as well.
Thank you.
Yeah, it was a good session.